the trevor lawrence tankathon continues
and listen
the tragedy of the jets is that they're
not intentionally tanking they're just
really bad
and if you're a jets fan
the idea of enduring
um
you know another
10 games of
uninspired play
led by adam gase
i didn't know there was a website called
takeathon
um another 10 games of uninspired play
by adam gase
um
you kind of you're weighing that against
well but if they fire them they might
fool around and win three games if they
fire them you almost kind of want them
to go on 16.
now i maintain michael that if i'm the
jets
and i know joe douglas didn't spend the
third overall pick i said this to you i
think it was last week before they all
run together every day is the same just
sun up sundown i said that you have a
talented young quarterback who you have
failed to support taking with the third
overall pick and sam darnold i know that
wouldn't joe douglas pick but
nonetheless i don't know what sam
darnold is or isn't at this point
so if i got the number one pick i'd be
i'd be put it up for auction but if
you're this is what i want to ask whoa
if you're trevor lawrence
right supposedly generational prospect
best since andrew luck coming off four
touchdowns
if you're trevor lawrence and the jets
have the number one pick oh are you not
the next andrew luck but are you the
next eli manning as in
now player
take that somewhere else i'm not playing
for the jets how do you play it if
you're trevor lawrence michael i'm
convinced now i know for sure
now i know for sure not only the cameras
are picking up
my activity in the house
you have tapped my phone too i was just
who are you talking telling you
none of your business you already know
don't pretend like you don't know
i don't know what you were talking about
what you do know because i was just
having this i'm telling you i had this
conversation with somebody oh is there
is there a book involved
it might be yes
okay i know okay i know you're talking
to okay i know you talking about
yeah with a very smart somebody
uh this morning and we had that
conversation that if you're trevor
lawrence
you absolutely
don't want to go to the jets not look
look i know always pick on the jets
and it's fun it's fun picking on new
york teams you know i i've lived in the
area that i've lived in for over 20
years it's just what people uh in this
part of the country do pick on new york
teams but
in this case it's not just new york if
you go back hey gary go back to that
list go back to that tankathon list and
let's see if we can find a common
denominator i think you'll see it and
i'm not making it up you can see it
right there it's clear as day go back to
that tankathon list and you'll see
okay
number one on the list
is the jets
then you got the washington football
team you got the giants
atlanta jacksonville and maybe the trend
stops at minnesota but all of them
all of them i'd say out of those top
five
four of those organizations are just a
mess
and have been like it's no accident that
your team is bad like the jets have been
bad for years and i know the giants have
the history of bill parcells and bill
belichick and they've won a couple of
super bowls with eli manning but what
the giants do they win super bowls
and then they go on these droughts
like the giants are terrible
washington's terrible atlanta i don't
know uh you know to fire my man thomas
mitchell jacksonville is terrible so
my point is
it's not just hey we lack talent no you
lack vision you lack organizational
vision and i don't think a guy like
trevor lawrence is going to go there and
be successful because the organization
doesn't know what it's doing
and it's just
a young guy in that situation
so here's the counter and i'm i don't
typically play devil's advocate it just
comes naturally but okay listen
i didn't mind when eli manning didn't
want to go to san diego at the time
i sir i was barely old enough i wasn't
enough to know about it but looking back
i don't mind john elway doing it when he
didn't want to go to the baltimore colts
and threaten to play baseball my man
said he was going to play baseball he
saves gold okay baseball this is not far
from my unprecedented and i believe you
know peyton stayed an extra year of
school i don't think i don't know that
that was the reason why but he
conveniently avoided getting drafted by
the jets stay in the city here that was
the reason
that what it was okay i didn't remember
if that was actually the reason okay got
it okay and parcells crazy about wasn't
crazy about playing for bill parcells
either anyway guys this is this
organization has been putrid for as long
as we can remember okay
all i would say though is this and by
the way going back to that list for a
second you know my jaguars are right
there in the mix they lost to the lions
yesterday so my jaguars that's the team
i've been rooting for because i just i'm
just fascinated with their bounty of
picks this is the franchise mode in me
that's talking yeah but
the team i would like to see him end up
at
is actually atlanta
um and not just because he played high
school ball in georgia
but i love to see that
the torch be passed but if you're
drafting trevor lawrence you're probably
not making him sit behind matt ryan
but that's the only organization
that i could that i think right you know
could be interesting enough like listen
if you don't want to go to the jets i
don't know why you want to go to
washington either and play for that
owner
exactly
the giants don't lack vision i'll be
excuse me the giants don't have that
much vision they got a great running
back but not much else beyond that so
there's a reason why all those teams are
up there to begin with like if you're
drafting that high
whether you have a tradition or not
you're struggling
so playing devil's advocate getting back
to that
if you'd have told baker mayfield that
he was going to be drafted by the browns
and look at the we don't know what baker
if he's that guy or not we overhyped him
his rookie year he struggled since but
you look at the history of brown since
they came back quarterbacks
not exactly that wouldn't inspire
confidence given a revolving door that
their organization has been at all the
important and now
joe burrows in cincinnati wait for joe
no no no no but i'm sorry but wait
notice what i'm saying no
i will say one thing and then i will
stop this is all i'm gonna say joe
burrows in cincinnati your trip now
cincinnati had a minute with marvin but
cincinnati ain't exactly a destination
even though he's from ohio that's not a
destination team if you are a savior
maybe the jets are just your cross to
bear if he's that dude why are you
laughing i'm making too much
advocate now i'm serious if trevor
lawrence is that dude
and he is the quarterback not that not
that new york deserves but the one it
needs
and he could go save the jets
he will be a god in new york
for the rest of his life and it's not
going to be adam gase it might not be
joe douglas making the pick what is this
why is this ridiculous i'm saying they
all go to bad teams at number one
what
what michael a smith the second don't
ever call me that again don't ever call
me that again
and you know why don't you ever call me
that again we only was understood need
not be spoken don't ever call me that
again go ahead
michael
yes
i'm with you
that's my version of mike
that's my and i've slipped up and called
you mike a few times you are you prefer
michael i know i showed people
they asked me hey what are you yeah you
want to be called mike or michael uh uh
michael okay michael yeah and then they
just get comfortable
i know i'm not that guy
i said my middle eastern is that same
thing with you
all right
on this not not on a previous show not
last monday tuesday wednesday thursday
on this show
what about this show
first guys
contradictory
i ain't talking about the browns anymore
the browns
ain't ready for it yeah yeah yeah so so
you're trying to talk like the browns
have overcome something they haven't
overcome oh no that's not what i'm
saying that's not what i'm saying
he would have said why didn't you tell
me earlier that this organization is so
hard to turn around look organizations
like that the browns haven't
accomplished anything the reason they've
struggled for so long is not talent the
browser countdown i gotta guarantee this
wait don't don't get off track wait
michael i got i gotta i gotta stop you
because you're going down the path that
we don't need to go down
if if it were about avoiding
awful organizations then nobody would
get drafted and i'm all for admit maybe
this is a conversation about the the
merits and the legality and the
principle of the draft espec please look
i just i just okay so if that's the case
why didn't baker mayfield or anybody why
did he pull a power move i know he
wasn't generational but why didn't he
say ah you know what uh john dorsey i'm
all set i don't want to be the latest in
a long line of quarterbacks whose
careers are going to cleveland to die he
could have said that joe burrow could
have been like you know what i'm not
really crazy about playing for the cheap
cincinnati bengals and mike brown no
thanks i haven't heard great things
about your organization i'm all for
player empowerment i love and i think
more of society will be receptive to
trevor lawrence saying you know what
this isn't for me i'm taking my career
in my own hands because the list is long
of quarterbacks who unfortunately have
been drafted into awful situations why
are you texting me while i'm on tv damn
i can't stand that it should be on me
but don't text me while i'm on tv you
should be watching the show anyway um
you know the list is long of awful
organizations that quarterbacks have
gone to and their careers have never
gotten on track because they weren't
supported so all i'm saying is that if
you're trevor lawrence if trevor
lawrence is that dude if he's everything
he's cracked up to be the jet's gonna
draft somebody if they don't if they
don't commit to sam darnold somebody's
gonna go in there and have to fix this
situation and if you're trevor lawrence
well like i don't i hear you this is
this way the chips fall that's all i'm
saying i hear i hear what you're saying
but you know what the patriots were
before drew bledsoe and before parcells
so you know what i do but you know what
but but listen oh that's a perfect
example that's a perfect example and and
i'll write down a list
but like when
when john elway
didn't want to go to baltimore
back in the day the old baltimore colts
he went to denver he immediately went to
a good franchise i didn't say he went to
a winning franchise
but he went to a good franchise they had
good ownership they had good fan support
they didn't have a john elway and then
immediately things worked out well for
him
i'm saying whether it's trevor lawrence
and and i would say don't get talked
into this oh you're afraid of a
challenge no this oh i'm not saying that
i'm not saying that i know you're not
saying it okay the new york jets are not
just a challenge the cleveland browns
are not just a challenge this is
infrastructure stuff so
trevor lawrence can't he can't turn it
around he he's going to be good he's no
not by himself it's above it's above his
pay grade it's it is it's the head it's
a head coach it's a gentleman ownership
ownership it's ownership
i can't stand woody johnson
or christopher johnson or whatever
whichever one of the johnson's like no
absolutely it is it feels like it is
beyond repair
until somebody fixes it and i'm not
saying trevor lawrence i'm with you it
by himself is going to come in and turn
water into wine i'm not saying he's
going to come in and go ahead multitude
that is not what i'm suggesting i am
simply saying that trevor lawrence
i don't know that he should be sitting
there necessarily saying
listen right now it looks bad they're
not going to have adam gates coach him
adam gates is not going to be the guy
coaching them
by the time the show is over okay so he
probably he probably won't make it to uh
november
right i'm saying that if trevor lawrence
is drafted by the jets
and it's like oh my god it's over for
trevor lawrence well you're telling me
that the jaguars organization has shown
so much better vision you're telling me
that the washington football is well
we're having the same conversation i
think the difference is
i think i wouldn't pull it i don't know
the power move is his only answer that's
i think that's the difference in our
opinion i don't know i just had to pull
apart i'd say the difference i think the
difference between let's say
john elway
in the early 80s
and even eli manning
in the early 2000s
the difference is you got a lot of
you got a lot of bad organizations
so it's hard to just say
it's hard to pick one that you don't
want to go to and find a multitude that
you do want to go to there are a lot of
bad organizations see the good news is
if you got the money this is this is why
i think this exists
if you got the money to buy into an nfl
team you absolutely should do it unless
you are a grade a maura
you're gonna make some money
buying an nfl team like if you got the
best tv deal in north america before you
do anything all you got to do is turn a
light on turn it can you turn on a light
if you can turn on a light you can make
money in the nfl just turn the lights on
you don't have to sell anything don't
sell a parking space don't sell a hot
dog turn the lights on and make sure
that they know where to wire your funds
from your tv contracts you're gonna make
money that's the good news so if you got
money invest in the nfl team the bad
news is
some people like jimmy heslam you call
him out
jimmy hesslem has money but has no idea
how to run a franchise and it's so
amazing to me mike let me just pick on
him just for a second
because i don't want to lose my the
bigger point it's amazing to me you know
jimmy heslam was part of the ownership
group minority owner in pittsburgh
like you would think didn't learn don't
you get it you know to learn something
yeah he's done the opposition he's been
the opposite of the bill we had coaches
in 50 years man three head coaches they
they just run it they're not they're not
impulsive they say hey here's the
franchise we're going to be stable and
he has done the opposite so
it's hard for a guy like trevor lawrence
i'm for him so that kind of puts your
face but it's harder to put it and more
listen in general more players listen i
i just i know i'm i don't mean to sound
like i'm talking about both sides of my
mouth which from time to time i could be
good at it but just understand what it
might be understand where i'm coming
from i would not i've never ever
begrudged a player for exercising his
leverage whether it's in contract
negotiations whether that's a draft if
trevor lawrence decides i am not putting
my career in the hands of this
organization i wouldn't blame him but
what i am saying though is i don't feel
like
it's a it's a given that he's going to
be ruined
if the jets draft him because this
iteration of the jets will not be around
to do the ruining you may be right that
it's just in the culture and there is no
fixing it
i tend to believe that there's somebody
whether it's another general manager
whether it's the right head coach they
will catch lightning in the bottle
so if and that's if they end up doing it
maybe they're smart enough to auction it
off like i said because the real power
move with you the jets is to get this
number one pick and say who wants it
because we're not a quarterback away who
wants it disaster and let somebody my
dad that's somebody like jacksonville
overpaid listen hey hey if trevor
lawrence
wants to come to the jets it doesn't
matter who drafts him if he's that kid
like joe burrow if he's that kid
only the jets would stay bye-bye only
the jets would be
okay okay new york joe okay
we got
we're all set i got you i know how funny
that sounds i know how funny that sounds
because it's crazy but wait because it's
straight no it's not crazy it's not
crazy because now
you are going to help me prove your
point that's why they're in this
position to begin with because you take
a quarterback with the third pick and
you ruin him and let him go flourish
somewhere else so yeah i knew right
he was wrong they're not they're not
helping he was already whatever he is he
was already whatever he is they ain't
helping so yes okay only the jets would
say we're all set with sam darnold until
the next big thing comes out in three
years like you know what trevor it's
been real we're gonna try this again
that's the problem build around the guy
you got you haven't given him a chance
to succeed you have not set him up must
succeed
you got it if he's the right guy now
listen you've got how do you know like
how do you know
do you think trevor lawrence
as a prospect
was the same let's go back to college
days it's trevor
i i know the jets have have terrible
coaches
um does they also have terrible scouts i
don't know i don't know uh
douglas uh came from baltimore so he he
has got good bloodlines
okay i'll say that have your scouts tell
you how did you rate sam darnold as a
prospect versus okay how do you rate
trevor i thought this guarantee i
thought i thought i thought we were
ending this conversation i thought this
conversation was winding down apparently
it's not first of all you don't know
with any of them and if you could tell
me that you can watch trevor lawrence
win 73 to 7 against georgia tech and
think you know that he's the real deal
with the talent that is surrounding him
at clemson i don't and i'm not trying to
knock you off trevor lawrence i'm not
trying to knock trevor lawrence i'm
saying is he more hyped coming out
then there's no hype coming out that sam
darnold uh was yes he is okay any
quarterback right trevor
listen
if you drop trevor lawrence in the
current jet situation michael he's not
gonna make a difference nobody can
tom brady yeah i couldn't come in and
fix the jets
i of course not but i i got what you're
saying but in general in general you
don't know it's a prospect and and the
draft is hard you got to project you
know how's this guy going to be uh in
his system how's this guy going to be if
you give him some money and give him
some responsibility the bright lights
all that stuff but there's a reason that
you've mentioned certain people
and those those players all turn out to
be good like john elway could have been
just another uh highly touted prospect
but he's a hall of famer peyton manning
could have been another highly touted
prospect he's a hall of famer eli
manning's gonna be in hall of fame one
day too andrew retired but he was well
on his way so those generational guys i
hope eli manning the scouts usually
don't miss on those guys and i'm just
trying to tell you that sam darnold no i
got you sam donald was not in that
conversation he was not in that
conversation
he was not see you later see you later
we can move hey how about we move on too
let's take a break because we got all
season i talk about this
i think i think we agree
more than our passion would suggest
i know we see we see team building and
much this this is why you know what you
know what the jets should do
hire us to co gm this thing
hire us
man we got our hands full general
manager what are you talking about from
another
dude we could totally turn around the
jets
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports